in how to murder your wife last year
varanelli she popped out of a cake and
men everywhere turned supermarkets
upside down looking for an instant mix
with that ingredient
it seems our man Flint found one because
he's here with her to present the next
award Byrne Alesi and James Coburn
what you could get sunspot no why
we'll be hanging around well in case
Verna breaks any English I can help
repair it God
ready money you begin please all right
for the outstanding achievement in
motion picture music there are two
categories first for the best music
score substantially original the
nominees are
Alex North for the agony and the ecstasy
Maurice Jarre for dr. Zhivago Alfred
Newman for the greatest story ever told
Jerry Goldsmith for a batch of new Anna
Sheila grin and Jacques Demy or the
umbrellas of Cherbourg please give this
please see the Empress thank you the
winner is Maurice Jarre
thank you very much it's a good
opportunity to me to say thank you
because it's a third is the second time
I get this big thing and I would like to
say to every member of the Academy thank
you but I don't forget my musicians
thank you very much and everything
because it's the second one also
the nominees for the best scoring
covenant music adaptation or treatment
default Cat Ballou Lionel Newman and
Alexander courage for the pleasure sixer
seeker urban coastal The Sound of Music
dan Walker for a thousand flowers
Monsieur mcgrann for the umbrellas of
Cherbourg what do you do it again the
winner is or win costume Sound of Music
my thanks go to Richard Rogers wonderful
music the great sound of Julie Andrews
voice the musicians who play the
glorious orchestral sounds 20 Century
Fox sound and Tadeo sound with Marie
Spivak and last of all of course Oscar
me thank everybody